how do you keep faith in yourself and in
your craft
during turbulent times boy is that a
good question
talk about dirty laundry um
you know there was i have this terrific
career coach
and her name is erica wernick she's
really fabulous i highly you should do
an interview with her you really should
she's just got a book coming out oh no
i'll send you her information
but please but you know she would
probably you know punch me in the arm
for saying this but
there was a time in my career early on
in the 90s where i was so frustrated
and and so down and didn't believe in
myself
and i just had this revelation i was
like you know what i've set a goal
i don't have to believe in myself i
just have to do the steps that i
committed to doing
to get me through the valley of the
shadow of death
and and that worked for me and it was a
device that worked for me and and i feel
like occasionally i still
have it i mean i think a lot of people
you know like erica talk about how
important it is
you know to believe in yourself and to
believe that your success is inevitable
and that's also very powerful um i just
find
that that my brain is a little more
complex in terms of
the things it does to me you know i
don't know that i'm always in the
driver's seat
and quite honestly i deal with
self-esteem issues i really do i mean i
think a lot of people do in this
business you know your identity is tied
up in your work
even if you don't want it to be because
you put so much of yourself into it
and if it doesn't do well or even if it
does well i mean
honestly the irony to me of having
something successful and praised
and then not having a lot of work that's
even worse than having something
criticized
because because at least if they
criticize that you're like okay it
sucked i get it
but if they say it's awesome and then
the jobs don't follow you're like
you know where's where's the karma
where's the payoff uh
you know we made a deal so so that's
harder for me
um but uh um
i do try to keep faith in myself and and
and you know honestly when when i
when i do have crises
with the system or success is a nebulous
thing
i i really i get basic and i go back and
i remind myself you know brad you're an
artist that was the contract you made
you never said you wanted to be rich i
don't
care about being rich i would like to be
self-sufficient i'd like to be
secure you know and if i was rich it'd
be okay but i'd
be donating and helping and i mean i'm
just i just don't need a
super yacht and an island um
but you know i remind myself that the
contract that i made was that i wanted
to be an artist
simple as that and you know what
i am i mean i just i look at the work
i've done
i work at the the work i'm doing and
even if
these people don't like it or those
people don't like it or even if
everybody likes it and i don't get a job
or an award
it's like you know what you gotta do the
work
you know somebody gave you the toys
somebody gave you the sandbox and they
let you build your sandcastle
and and that's enough do you think a lot
of success is luck
or success can be orchestrated
i want to believe it can be orchestrated
you know and i know
you know people who who feel very
strongly about that
and and i feel
i feel it can be influenced you know i
don't know if i believe it can be
orchestrated in a guaranteed way because
because for for a hundred people doing a
hundred
things more or less the same they're
gonna have
different outcomes you know because
they'll know different people they'll be
at different moments in time
it'll be a different project um you know
they may have a different
mode to their personality or their
energy or you know
i don't know i mean it could be simple
simple things
you know i give you an example i mean i
have people who
message me out of the blue and if people
message me
and they have a specific question and
they say brad what light did you use in
that
particular scene or they say um you know
would you look at my resume
i respond to them you know people who
who hit me up and they say
how are you doing i just don't even
answer because
how do i i don't i don't need any small
talk and how do i answer that
you know it's like so so the point being
is that
is that um you know the way you interact
with the world
be it me or be it those person persons
emailing me
you're going to get a different response
depending
depending on what you put out there and
i've forgotten your question but i hope
i answered it
oh you did you did i think you said it
because i was saying is a success do you
think a lot of it's luck
or it can be orchestrated and so it
sounds like it might be sort of a
combination
it's it's got to be it really has to be
because because
you know it's it's what is it they say
success
is is preparation meeting opportunity
right you know you have to be prepared
you know if you go into that meeting if
you luck out and you get that meeting
but you
you don't know squat you're not going to
impress them
but if you are a genius and you're an
introvert and
won't go out and do the meetings then
you're still stuck
and just for anybody who's an introvert
i am a terrible introvert i am so shy
but i want this more than i want to be
shy so i just
you know i'm not an actor but in that
way i am an actor
you know i will i will go do the act and
i'm not always good
you know if i'm in a crowd and i don't
anybody and i don't have a wingman
that's kryptonite
i shut down and i sit in the corner to
this day i'm ashamed of it but i
just i'm i'm just i had powerless but
you know i know to have a wingman i
don't have somebody else to help me
you know or at least find oh i know that
person they can introduce me you know i
mean that's
you know um but you know when i was a
little kid i um
you know i would just my mom would say
you know you want to you want a slurpee
and
and she would you know i'd be sitting in
the car and and she said we have to go
in and get it i would just sit there and
cry because i didn't want to go in
by myself i was so shy um but
so it was hard you know but uh
you know you just if you want something
enough then you
do the things you need to do one of my
favorite sayings right now and
because i'm looking to level up i mean
look i could be at the top and i'd still
be looking to level up
but there's this great saying and it's
if you want something you've never had
before you have to do something you've
never done before
and sometimes that might be obvious but
sometimes it's surprising like
just the other day i had this
realization because i'm a workaholic and
i drive myself like
crazy i was reading erica's book as a
matter of fact
meant for this go out and buy it it's a
really good book
but i had a thought that was really kind
of a non-sequitur it wasn't really
relevant to what i was reading but i
thought
i thought brad you need
quiet time you need to stop and just be
quiet whether you meditate
or or just watch the world go by because
you don't do that
and that's surprising because my logical
brain says well that's not going to
get you anywhere but then i start
thinking you know because i know that
that you just can't go
24 hours even though i have because you
wear down you you lose your acuity
so so you maybe that is the thing maybe
i need
more breaks and more quiet time because
maybe that will make the time i do
spend working just
that more focused and that more
effective you know
um you know it's better to to spend
five really effective minutes than than
an hour
kind of unfocused and tired and
distracted
so so that was the thing that i thought
well you know that's interesting because
that's a thing i haven't done before and
it's it's not what i would have guessed
you know but that's that's just kind of
the thing is is that um
um you know and and the other thing
about success is
people when people ask advice for about
success
or about being a cinematographer or
being on set or meeting people or
networking
everybody wants the formula they want
the road map they want the a b
c equals d and i get that
because as humans i think we're wired
that way i want that but guess what i've
never found it
it's just it's just always different
it's a moving target
and and you learn as you go and you you
take your best guess and you try it and
if it doesn't work then you're like okay
it's not working i'm not gonna quit but
let me try something different let me
revise it can i go this way can i go
that way
can i show up with flowers and chocolate
can i you know get my buddy to do an
introduction
you know whatever you know
it's not about stopping it's about it's
about okay this isn't working let's
think of something else let's reinvent
and even something that
does work for a while just like the
market changes just like the technology
changes it's like you know what
it used to work it's not working now try
something different
so being internal an introvert maybe
needing quiet time
did that work for you growing up in
houston
and how did you turn that like if you
needed to turn on that and i'm just i'm
just stereotyping here the southern
charm and
being sort of you know larger than life
which you do have that side to you i can
see it but
how would you manifest that if you had
to walk into a room and sort of own it
if i know people it's easy you know
if i know some people it's easy um but
part of it is having generosity towards
the other person
i think that um
one of the things that i tell young
people is is if you approach
a relationship if you want a meeting or
you want to connect with somebody
do not approach it from what can they do
for me
i am going to ask them for a job i am
going to ask them
to give me something the best way to
approach it is to be like
what can i give them you know
what do i have to offer and and
um you don't have to be an experienced
filmmaker we are
blessed with social media where we
consider this person
likes going out on a boat this person
likes dogs
and that person likes to paint and this
person maybe went to your
school and this person maybe
is friends with your uncle i don't know
but we have the ability to do due
diligence on people in a way that is
just never been possible before i do
that
and i recommend that people do that you
know and you go
and you you do your homework and then
they're not a stranger
you know because you have you find that
thing oh you know they like
comic books or oh they like this their
favorite movie is my favorite movie or
or they like the same band i like
that takes a lot of the the edge off of
because the part of the fear is like i
don't know what to say
but you know if you guys both like
doberman pinschers now you have
something to talk about
and and it's lovely for the other person
because you know what all day long
they're getting calls oh give me a job
you know i want to be a pa will you make
my movie
and they're like oh you want to talk
about my dog oh here's a picture of my
dog they're so happy
you know and that's that's the thing
because you have to remember this is a
business of relationships
it's not a business of of like parasites
and
and and and and prey you know it's it's
it's your friends you want you want to
work with your friends you're going to
call your friends you're going to work
with your friends
everybody likes hanging out with their
friends you know and this is a business
where you have the ability to hire the
people you like
you know and and you know people who are
it's just like in your life
think about you know that one friend who
always asks you for something they
always want you to
come over to their house and do them a
favor and and buy
lunch and they never reciprocate how how
excited are you to spend time with that
person you know
but think about the other person who
calls you up and says oh there's this
new movie and you would love it
you know that's the person you're happy
to hear from so
you know when i meet with people i try
to be able to offer that and also when i
follow up and in social media i'm like
oh hey here's an article i know you like
butterflies here's a
butterfly article um
and and it's not just um
you know a cynical thing because because
i think it's cool that they like
butterfly like it's neat so
that's cool um so when i'm in a in a
position of meeting people one of the
things that that
mindset precipitates
is that it makes you listen because you
don't know what people want if you don't
listen to them
and a lot of people will tell you that
in meetings you don't want to do a lot
of talking you want to listen
and then talk strategically and and to
the point
and so i think if you listen you know
people are going to tell you
their story and they're going to tell
you what they need and i've had that
many
times where they're like oh and i was on
the shoot and there was this thing
and i'm like oh yeah well you know the
next time you have that happen let me
know because i know a guy
you know or oh well let me tell you what
i did once in a similar situation
um and and i think that's you know again
you're being friends
and i literally years ago
stopped leading with my website
like the most aggressive thing i'll do
now is put it
in my signature because if people
are interested they're going to look for
it you know
i reach out and talk to them about their
doberman pinscher or their horse or
their butterflies i mean that's how i
build it or i compliment them like oh i
you know that commercial you did was
really beautiful
or oh hey you know i'm also friends with
so and so um
and you know i'll do i've done lunches
with people you know and we spend
you know and this is somebody that yeah
i'd love to work with them
and we spend the whole lunch talking
about nothing having even remotely to do
with film
and as we're getting up to leave
they say send me your work i might have
something coming up you know
but how much more powerful is it for
them to ask
than for me to be like oh you know look
at my stuff
you know because they get that all day
long again you know you just don't want
to be that person i don't want to be
that maybe somebody does but i don't
want to be that person
so so that's how i handled it i i fee it
and it also it takes the pressure off
i have nothing to prove i'm not selling
anything i'm not a salesman
i would be a horrible salesman you know
but i'm pretty i'm pretty good at being
nice to people
i'm pretty good i mean something i care
a lot about is other people is
you know how can i help them what up and
you know again
maybe it's not even me maybe it's like
oh you should meet this person
i'm really good about that you know just
be a matchmaker of
of like oh these two people need to meet
and sometimes it's obvious why they
should meet and sometimes it's just like
y'all have similar personalities and i
don't know what's going to come of it
but you should know each other so
that's that's my answer to your question
as a shy person you know how do you
go in there is i i go in there with a
sense of generosity and relating as a
human as opposed to a salesperson
you